but it was great in your jeans talk to
hear public media kind of called out in
this way both you know we're sort of
used to in our traveling's within the
public media world to either be beating
up on ourselves or patting their own
back into here called out in a way that
actually sets up a promise and a purpose
within the context of the Broadband Plan
and point the way to this discussion
which is going to try to talk about some
of the challenges of this transition
that we as a an industry are in and not
dissimilar to some other media moments
that are happening so my name is Jack
Shapiro I'm executive director of PR X
the public radio exchange in many ways
we're one of these born digital new
public media enterprises we operate as
an open distribution platform connecting
independent producers with local
stations really as a hybrid between
broadcast and digital opportunities and
trying to focus on the intersection of
Technology and talent they're trying to
nurture new voices and content and
there's been a long term interest in
this topic of the transition of public
broadcasting in public media into the
participatory culture it's a we're at a
nexus of opportunities we've see
disruption in other media industries
that we have observed in music in
particular which has been an interest of
ours and in newspapers that I know the
knight Foundation's report has really
focused on where that's coming up to two
genes point about mediated versus
unmediated I think one of the themes I'm
hoping will emerge from this
conversation is if you take seriously
the role of being a mediator still in
this age how are we addressing that
through the the public media system a
word about when we're describing public
media there's definitional issues that
are bound to come up we have here with
us really a group of public
broadcaster's in many ways were I think
all discussing public media is radiating
out from and well beyond the boundaries
of what public broadcasting has
traditionally been constituted to be how
much can include and has been referenced
public access television low-power
and other nonprofits engaged in public
service media activities there's there's
an interesting question especially as we
get into some of the opportunities ahead
as to where some of those boundaries end
up getting drawn especially as you talk
about potential reform or even
legislation that might change some of
the definitions so what I'd like to do
you know what's one thing about this
panel is that rather than policy makers
or policy observers or academics we have
a bunch of practitioners here who are
really engaged in the day-to-day of
building next kind of public media
architecture infrastructure operations
across the spectrum of roles so in order
to get our heads around the opening of
where this transition to digital public
meeting is headed and ask each one to
sort of introduce themselves and in
doing so address the topic as they'd
like but also talk about a project or a
particular initiative that is
illustrative of what we think this next
incarnation of public media might be and
I guess I'll just start to my left so
please introduce yourself from sharp
Robert bowl I'm with the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting and my role is to
lead our digital strategy and
investments I think one of the central
themes that I see and I'm relatively new
to public broadcasting I came from an
organization that worked in public media
with low-income populations and then
moved into this role about 10 months ago
and one of the great things that I see
happening one of the reasons why I was
so attracted to coming over and working
in public broadcasting is this a the 22
mediating influences one was that you
have the power to broadcast the power to
broadcast means that you can reach
everyone in the United States with free
and universally accessible content in
general and that that is not necessarily
true in the digital world that the
digital content costs money to get
access to and to utilize so the ability
to mix broadcast and digital platforms
seem to be to be a great opportunity for
where public meetings going I also saw
organizations and people like these that
we're starting to turn public media
from a purely broadcast environment to a
more of a platform approach where there
were other types of collaborations other
types of voices and other types of
opportunities to get information out
into the into the world that are
non-traditional and so those two things
are sort of in full swing in terms of I
so desperately want to talk about the
public media platform but I know Kensi's
going to want to talk about that but I
want to talk about one thing that I
think is a little unusual or it's a
little changing and that is what some of
the role of where prx and where a number
of other folks are in developing a
series of very flexible applications
whether their own mobile platforms or
online that allow people to engage and
participate WNYC is a good example of
that in New York it's doing work about
sort of uncommon economic indicators
where they're actually asking people
from the community to start to
crowdsource knowledge about what's
happening in their community it's all
centralized around a broadcast a radio
broadcast but it is being visualized on
the online space which is generating
even more broadcast so that opportunity
to really sort of have this engaged
conversation in that space is really
adding a great value and it's an example
of very flexible very agile tools coming
to bear in an industry of broadcast
industry which can also mean a lot of
capital and a lot of in flexibility
because some of the rules around that
broadcast so there's a lot of very
interesting sort of dynamic happening I
am marina Rivero I'm a vice president at
wgbh the public broadcaster here and I'm
the general manager for radio and
television which now means here the
general manager for mobile video fans
etc etc etc I find this a moment of
great opportunity and an interest as
well we started in public broadcasting
thinking about radio and television it's
been well over a decade since the work
we've done really has moved on to create
specific projects for for many media
devices and using many tools so i think
i'm here from the
spective of producers kind of the edit
the editorial side of what's happening
in public broadcasting and Jake
suggested I use as an example a large
national project that that we're
beginning to work on called world 2.0
which is an online civic engagement
project we're really asking the public
to help us define some of the issues of
the day and we're really looking how we
might target in fact younger a younger
I'll point a finger at 36 but a younger
population of people and putting from in
front of that group opportunities to
begin to become more engaged and share
information about what's happening and I
was thinking about this I wrote down you
know four or five things that I think
are distinctive as we as public
broadcaster's the traditional public
broadcaster's have engaged over this
time I think we use our strengths as
curators when you know we talk about
news and journalism loses the primary
example of curation and we're past grand
masters at taking very complicated
issues and be able to present them back
in ways that allow people to address
them and digest them public
broadcaster's have a national base as
we've done work with many of the new
media providers and partnered with new
media provides we realize one of the
strengths we bring is that there are
stations and communities all across the
country and being able to partner
outside public traditional public
broadcasting means that we share a
number of things one of them is that
particular reach we can use our current
investments that's what this project
imagines we've put money into building
the National Black programming
consortium and that consortium has
connections with the African American
community all across the country there
are opportunities for us to take
investments that we've made in that and
many other communities that we've
developed over time and think about how
we bring them back together reformat
them using the capabilities we have now
to have that voice part of the issues
obviously we're looking at
a grammar that attracts people that's
what we do we try to take some of the
data and the things that might otherwise
be dry and turn them into the
possibility of bringing people in if we
can't do that we're out of the route of
the business and finally I just say that
you know we're looking at obviously
right now a kind of transmedia and
really distributed model of programming
so these are these are kind of five
areas that I think some of them are
unique to public broadcaster's
established public broadcasting but for
us they've all been part of what we've
been experimenting with and what we're
intending to bring into the world to
point o project to look at a broader
group of people coming together to
empower themselves and talk about the
issues of the day im sue shart I'm the
executive director of air which is based
here in Dorchester the association of
Independence and radio it's an
organization that's 21 years old it's
one of the oldest and largest membership
professional membership organizations in
public media and what we haven't just
briefly in terms of the organization
it's a very broad group spanning ages
from about 18 to 70 years old we have
practitioners who have been in the
business for 35 plus years who helped
laid down the pipe lines in the earliest
days of the industry to the youngest and
most emerging group of media
practitioners hope and hopefully we can
talk more about that a little bit later
we had a project this last year makers
quest 2.0 funded by the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting that was a
tremendous demonstration project cpb
came to us and asked us to help figure
out how producers how individual
inspired producers could help lead the
industry through the transition from
public radio to public media and what we
saw emerged was
really some just tremendous fodder and
tremendous information and models for us
briefly I would welcome invite you to
look there's a brief video mq 20 RG
which will give you more of a scope on
the projects but briefly what the
principle behind the project is that the
change is happening from the bottom up
it's individuals who are leading the
change it's the craftspeople who are
leading who are on the front edge and it
front edge of what's happening and so
what we did was we basically turn to
them and you know these nimble not risk
averse very crafty people who figure
stuff out for a living and said to them
how can we blend traditional platforms
the power of the converged audience that
we have in public radio which is
tremendous with these new digital this
new circulation system these new digital
tools and pathways we gave them five
months we gave them forty thousand
dollars each and they came and I won't
again won't go into detail here but what
we saw come out of this were they
invented new formats participatory
documentary documentary they went into
the communities we partnered them each
with incubators so they they were
incubated sort of seated four of them at
NPR one of them at KPCC in Los Angeles
one at kuow in Seattle WNYC and so they
had this relationship but retained their
independence and their freedom to invent
that so that that's a project that i
would say demonstrates the new face of
the public media journalists where we
still see these gifted individuals again
a varying degrees of experience to some
were very inexperienced and some were
much more experienced but basically in
the role still is jake is mentioning as
a mediator still the person who is
gifted at identifying good stories and
good storytellers
and then figuring out how to get that
story out but the whole landscape in
terms of the tools that they can use is
what's changed and this is what this is
what they figured out they don't have to
go out with the microphone themselves
and ask somebody a question and gather
half an hour of tape and go back and cut
it up into four minutes and you know put
it out on the radio station it's a whole
different participatory model these are
participatory models that they invented
that they're tremendously exciting hi
I'm Kinsey Wilson and senior vice
president and general manager of digital
media at NPR which means about half of
my time is spent serve on the operations
of NPR's digital media operations and
the other half is sort of gazing into
the future and trying to figure out what
NPR's future and stations future digital
strategy will be I've been in journalism
for 30 years but in digital media for
about 15 and like Rob and relatively new
to public media haven't been there about
15 months a couple of the speaker's made
reference to the the enormous
technological disruption that's going on
and for us from where we sit it's it's
created both an imperative and an
opportunity the imperative Eugene
referred to in terms of public
broadcasting having to move from sort of
its 20th century analogue broadcasting
model to its 21st century digital future
and make sure that it can make that
transition the opportunity is one that
that I think has become much more
evident just in the last couple of years
as both the technological transformation
has accelerated and the challenges the
business model around journalism have
become accentuated and we see an
opportunity that one of our board
members of meeting the other day summed
up as saying that we need stronger more
vibrant news organizations in more
places I would add to that they reach
larger and more diverse audiences across
all platforms it's it's an ambition that
even just a couple of years ago probably
would have been beyond the scope of
public media but because the
technologies and the tools have become
lighter and because
is monopoly or near monopoly news
organizations that completely dominated
the local market are beginning to see
their franchise of road and the
opportunity is opening up for lots of
different players to come in there is a
real opportunity for public media to
step into that space so our efforts have
been focused really in two directions to
try and help stations figure out what
the best opportunity is in that space
and where the appropriate divide is if
you will between services and guidance
that can be provided at a national level
economies of scale that can be provided
at the national level and where the
opportunity is best left to the
bottom-up kind of creativity that Sue
was describing and so we've got two
projects underway one is aimed at sort
of understanding the audience
proposition what will attract people
what is the best editorial journalistic
audience play for public media in these
local markets because there are lots of
different choices that you can make and
it's very hard for individual properties
to figure that out one by one so we're
trying to provide some guidance there
and have a project underway in 12
different markets that actually launch
today with the signing of a contract
with the cpb around that that will be
attempting to in essence do rapid
prototyping over the next two years of
some local news sites in those markets
the other sort of trailing behind that
but began with what Eugene referred to
as the NPR API is an effort to create a
common platform and think about
networking public media content however
that's ultimately defined in some sort
of common repository the larger goal of
which is to encourage the kind of
innovation that needs to go on at the
local level to in essence stimulate
open-source development on top of that
repository and give people the tools
with which to invent the next generation
of news gathering so one piece is sort
of intellectually focused on what the
audience proposition
the other very much on infrastructure
and platform and common standards and
economies of scale in a way that sounds
almost just striking out of the analogy
to what might be the collected assets of
public media made available through an
open platform is the is the data gov
proposition where then you hope and
encourage further innovation to happen
on top of that collected content and
then the sources of that content and
like not being government sources this
is where I think the conversation get
interesting is when you're talking about
the first incarnation of the platform
thinking about NPR content or the
related partners national producers but
then we might get to where Sue's per
view into a much broader range of
individual creators or others who are
not necessarily holders of licenses to
bits of spectrum so one question that i
would like anybody to jump in on go
through on first is as we think about
this transition we've talked about a few
of the assets already that we bring
forward with it existing knowledge and
expertise even in storytelling in this
mediation roll some powerful
relationships community organizations
across the country that are already in
place and providing valued serviced over
broadcast one of the ones also that is
interesting in contrast to the declining
trust in other institutions nationally
government Congress being examples that
were just brought up is the trust in
public media brands the ones that are
best known is actually very high and in
many ways growing but what if you were
looking at it in the two of you who are
newest to the system as we call the
system might have particular insight in
this are the are the hindrances we have
you know you can mention another asset
that maybe I didn't mention that we're
bringing in but what are the ones that
you actually see is obstacles to public
broadcasting playing a fundamental role
in the new space all right yeah I think
I think there are two that i would i
would say i think one of the really you
were talking about one of the great one
of the great assets of public
broadcasting is localism and i think one
of the
great challenges of public broadcasting
is localism meaning that we have 800
plus independent businesses with their
own boards with their own you know
balance sheets with their own
infrastructure that can work together
have the opportunity to work together
but sometimes it's hard so you have
uneven distribution of capacity whether
it's a small little radio station done
by two people in Marfa Texas to gbh or
some of the larger producing stations so
I think that's one of the one of the big
challenges and I think CPP's role in
that challenge as well as NPR and PBS
and other other big organizations is to
start to make some systematic wide
investments in things that Kinzie was
talking about in terms of public media
platforms and another project i would
cite which would be one that i'm working
on is called the American archive which
is not a news based archive though I
think jeans point about helping and
trying to help improve the ability for
people to get access to journalism
content is very important the American
archive is a much larger archive than
just journalism and we have to we have
to understand that public media is you
know something that is very much
involved in education in arts and
cultural life and it's amazing actually
I have a little thing right now for the
American Playhouse if anyone remembers
that I just got a book with all of the
American play house productions and it's
you know it's every significant actor
producer writer or director in today's
Hollywood scene has creative 35 has
created content for the American
Playhouse series like every single one
and they didn't do it for commercial
interests they didn't even really do it
for themselves they did it for the
American public but it's hard to get
access to that material because of the
mirror rights issues so I think if I was
going to talk a little bit about some of
the big challenges it's is that question
of how do you even capacity and I think
technology infrastructure equal access
to very robust flexible technology
infrastructure whether it's something
that is put together by an NPR PBS
working together or whether it's
something put together by outside
entities like Google or
go or what not are very important as
well as this addressing of this digital
rights issue that American public has
made significant investments in this
fantastic stuff but you know what you
can't get access to it just on on the
obstacle side I guess depending on what
Rob was saying I you know as I look at
sort of this transformation over the
last 15 years over and over again you
see that that the organizations that
have the greatest difficulty are those
whose legacy structure governance
whatever profoundly inhibits their
ability to make this transition to to
take the risks to make the investments
that they need to because they're their
loyalties are divided or structurally
they're simply not set up and organized
to do this and I did you know clearly
that's that's one of the challenges that
public media faces I'm quite optimistic
though and particularly coming having
come out of the newspaper industry and
having watched what occurred there
public media is generally operating from
a position of strength public radio's
audience has grown sixty-seven percent
between 1998 and 2008 while programming
most other news programming has declined
on other platforms traditional legacy
platforms we are not rocked back on our
heels as we're trying to make this
transformation we actually enjoy trust
reach a vibrant news organization and
can build from there and I think have
become aware of the necessity of moving
quickly at a time when we're still
strong and that unfortunately newspapers
when their cash flow was at its zenith
in 2002 2003 we're not as quick to act
are now finding it very difficult to
respond to the technological challenges
that they face you go ahead
I would just add up one sort of another
dimension to what Kenzie is seeing here
in terms of the legacy and the culture
you know a public radio is an
institution that is a phenomenal success
story I mean it's a 35 year old
institution that has basically just had
straight straight straight growth an
audience in revenues and in penetration
and just evolving into the the you know
the very respected institution that it
is it boils down to the people in an
understanding that the people who
started this whole enterprise 35 years
ago are in large part still the ones who
are with it that they've ridden this way
they're the architects of success and
here they are at a point at this
incredibly you know this time where
there's this tremendous seismic shift
going on and what they were hired to do
and what they did extremely well was
billed as you know this amazing
institution and now suddenly they're
supposed to somehow you know change
everything or or help it through this
whole transformation and I think it's a
really basic kind of awareness that we
have to have that if that's not they did
their job it's not their job to
necessarily come up with the
transformation the answer to the
transformation and the agent the agency
of transformation isn't those who are
sort of holding the you know sort of
holding the keys to the kingdom so there
needs to be a very sort of it's kind of
simple but it's a powerful kind of
awareness that needs to happen within
the institution and I don't think our
industry is alone i'm sure this this is
this happens you know all the time with
industries that that enjoy tremendous
success it's really hard for those
gatekeepers who did their job and they
did it extremely well in who are sort of
looking at you know retirement you know
they're they're moving out how to make
that transition the other thing I would
just add quickly is that related to this
is there's a tremendous gap in
infrastructure and investment we have
this so we have this legacy at
this institution that is under siege
with the economy and and tremendous
amount of money being pushed into it to
keep it short up to keep the lights
going to keep the electricity on at a
time when we have such a need again of
this nimble kind of risk taking energy
and enterprise and there's a real gap in
the infrastructure and how we actually
fund that how we actually make that
happen in dollars and cents nothing I
wanted to hear from you and then also
from reto in the parallel of assets
versus obstacles the fundamental piece
of the architecture about broadcasting
is a local station a local entity and
there's a lot of ways of thinking around
and beyond that but what is that role
going forward yeah that's that's
actually where I want to follow up I
think there's a couple of things to be
said I mean again I want to reiterate I
came from the digital media world where
I had no ability to transmit and now i'm
working in public broadcasting where we
do have the ability to transmit and
that's a really incredibly efficient
thing to do you build a tower and you
sink some costs into that but the cost
of adding more clientele to the get that
signal is pretty much zero you know you
the cost of transmitted to one is it
cost to transmit to a million and that
is not true that's not the same scale in
digital media and so those local
institutions all that those local
organizations are truly these amazing
anchor institutions in their community
you know they have the ability to
collaborate and to curate they have the
ability to work with the local community
in new ways and provide content and
broadcast into into schools into
healthcare clinics into people's homes
and so I think that before we give up on
the infrastructure that we spent the
last 35 years building we should realize
that there's still a lot of energy a lot
of power in that and that infrastructure
is tied to staff on the ground as Marita
said in every community in the country
including Marfa Texas you know when
there are two dedicated people out there
trying to tell the public story and I
think that's a really important you know
a really important point
I think just lastly in terms of localism
and stations there is a transformation
that's going on in those stations we
have to balance really savvy media
executives who understand how to run a
media operation with people like me who
are coming in and who'd never run a
broadcast media operation and who
understand how to do new things in new
ways and there's that balancing point
that's important we don't you know I am
you know so so wrapped up in the notion
that our stations are the opportunity we
have to provide an up to provide for
voice in our community and a scale
that's not really available to us in
many other instances and I find this
what I'm dealing with partnerships now
people inside and outside public
traditional public broadcasting that
question of voice to me is one thing I I
hope we don't see at risk you know as we
as we move toward new ways of engaging
with the public and it's one of the real
opportunities I see certainly in a local
community with the tools that we have
now we're finding as a station that this
is when we can go to Dorchester this is
when we can stop talking about you know
populations in our community who have no
way to talk to us to themselves I think
becoming the vehicle for those kind back
kind of dialogue and shared information
is a is very exciting to me it's very
exciting because that's we can do more
of that now than we used to be able to
do and I see that with our local
television you know our basic black
that's suddenly doing live programmes
with the dialogue is right online that
their community video reporters that
their bloggers we look at somewhere we
call the lab open calls what you're
doing locally and then nationally which
are calls for people to upload video to
really participate in the dialogue
that's that's being addressed through
the other platforms so I would say that
the ability for those local stations to
continue to partner with organizations
outside of themselves is critical so
it's want to move from the broadcast
portion of the event of the
participatory
and so if you have questions again
please go to the microphones on the side
and also if you're watching the stream I
did manage to get online and if you want
to tweet a question in or want to open
the panel before us we're going to
iterate so just tweet me Jake Shapiro
i'm just at jake's vero and hopefully
i'll see you here in the direct message
while we're gathering at the microphones
I wanted to ask us a question about the
the business model is a strength so
we've you know often describing limited
resources of public broadcasting and the
strains between the under capitalization
of the tax funded dollars and the
strains that public coverage in
particular has to do around pledge and
underwriting and sponsorship but in some
ways in the kinsey you were sort of
alluding to this that that diversified
business model and certainly the direct
reliance in relationship we have with
people pledging money to support
something that they value could be seen
as a strength do you see that actually
is something that is a little thing we
not only could carry forward but map
beyond what we've done so far I think it
not only could be seen as a strength I'm
increasingly come to appreciate just how
essential our diversified revenue model
is to our independence to our ability to
be able to report without fear or favor
and to being able to weather the kind of
technological disruption that we're
going through now again having come from
commercial media one of the things that
that you're seeing happen right now is
the the extreme dependence on
advertising revenue really drives all
conversations at a moment like this
where revenues are declining where
they're trying to make adjustments in
the business and we're fortunate in
having a relatively even mix between I
mean in the case of NPR it's about
twenty eight percent of our revenue
comes from corporate sponsorship little
under fifty percent comes from licensing
which at the station level comes from
listener support and the licensing
meaning state fees the stations pay for
the programming right and then the
remainder from
foundation and gifts and a very small
proportion in our case comes from the
federal government so that may change
over time how that business model
translates in the digital era remains to
be seen I've got a lot of ideas about
how that can happen but it is absolutely
a source of strength let's start with
the microphone what please listen to
Erik wolf from PBS actually but this is
actually more of a personal personal
question personal background Eugene in
his talk talked about the notion of
public media as a source of social
cohesion I think or societal cohesion
the media today is more and more
fragmented right the right listens to
Fox the left listens to MSNBC somebody
else listens to CNN people people go
into their corners and listen to what
they want to hear can you all talk about
how you see and marita I think you just
started to maybe touch on this how you
see public media being having an
opportunity to provide societal cohesion
as we get into a more and more
fragmented world we work hard we work
hard not to be put in a box and I think
it's essential that we maintain that
maintain that as we move forward and if
there's if there's any box are trying to
get out of it's the it's the tone of
voice box you know it's the it's the
creative boxes the grammar box that's
why I don't know what you're talking
that's a different box from the you know
how we are being viewed and I think this
point about being trusted purveyors of
information is core because as media
proliferate yes you've got five
different six different ten different
things you're looking for we need to
make sure the public media public
broadcasting remains one of your five
choices if that's what you have and
people will I think respond to that as
as a cacophony that goes on so our role
is to think about how we invite the
participation now invite some shared the
development of shared
faced with other communities so that it
isn't all just us talking talking
talking ducky but really providing the
space for those communities to talk to
one another we attract people but they
have no way to talk to one another and
if we agree with the view that
intelligence has been passed out evenly
among communities rich poor ethnic you
know trans mediate whatever national
part of our role is to convene those
people who want to bring intelligence to
bear on on some of the many issues in
front of us and I think that role for us
is being is becoming more possible
because of the tools that we have in
hand Nolan Bowie again I'm a former
public interest communications lawyer
longtime advocate for public
broadcasting I support both public
broadcasting stations here in Boston I
say that his background as we all know
not all media are regulated in the same
manner by government broadcasting is
much more deeply and widely regulated
than all other media what makes
broadcasting different is the legal
fiction of spectrum scarcity the
so-called scarcely rationale Justice
Clarence Thomas in a concurring decision
this summer in August release an
occasion title FCC vs fox more or less
invited a challenge to the broadcast
regulation based on in a tack on First
Amendment grounds and First Amendment
grounds in the Citizens United the court
it seems to treat the First Amendment
sacrosanct almost as if it was absolute
the same rationale its applied to
broadcasting would probably hold
brockett this court but a whole
broadcasting regulation is being
unconstitutional I'd like to ask the
panel in general
to regard a more consistent way of
regulating broadcasting consistent with
First Amendment goals and principles
what they think should buy cassie not be
regulated as a common carrier first come
first served non-discrimination no
censorship and a separation of the
owners of the Stations of the conduit
from content to give everyone an equal
opportunity to speak who wants to jump
in on that one I'd like to phone a
friend see I know you have some friends
in the audience prob snack I mean I'm no
policy person at all I mean just very
briefly from a broadcaster standpoint
you know we have an 11-percent
penetration into the American public and
we do that we do that but you know by
virtue of what we put out we reflect who
we attract as an audience and I think
it's you know it's clear that we have a
tremendous opportunity now in this age
that we're in to penetrate beyond the
eleven percent I think we're all
committed to doing that in finding ways
to do that using again the momentum that
we have going right now to reflect a
more broadly a democratic more colorful
and diverse America I think that that I
don't know if that exactly answers your
question but could we did it right so is
the question in a way when the
transition starts and public media is
serving perhaps equally or even more so
through digital channels that the
broadcasts that it retains the spectrum
that it retains should be managed
differently than it's currently managed
so that we should actually you know what
one stations perhaps are primarily now
serving audiences through digital
platforms then the existing spectrum
that we've operated in a certain
programming approach here suggesting
perhaps might be operated differently
right I'm going to switch the next time
because we don't I don't think anybody
here is ready to dump in Kenzie okay hi
I'm Stefan Thomas here on the director
of citizens market where a new nonprofit
in Boston and we're interested in
connecting consumers with information
about corporate behavior both large
companies and small local companies my
question is really for any of the
panelists we've heard a lot of really
interesting things today about how
communities engage the public sector but
since you have your ear down to the
ground with what communities are doing I
wonder if you have any interesting
stories about changes in how communities
are engaging the private sector this
might be local plants from large
companies are also local companies
themselves have you seen any shifts or
interesting things happening in that
area thanks you know actually can I
wouldn't mind prompting where NPR
romantic there's a big focus on
accountability journalism students to be
the next area where a lot of public
media stations are thinking about
investing even more resources and I'm
wondering as definitely from NPR or from
NPR what you see about that I mean I
think there's a there's a huge
opportunity at sort of the intersection
of data and journalism if you will and
and that's one of the focuses of you
know where we're starting to put some
energy into investigative reporting and
accountability journalism I was involved
in the project actually my former
employer at USA Today where we did very
elaborate mapping of the point emissions
from manufacturing concerns all over the
country and they have to report to the
EPA but the data that comes out is
virtually unintelligible when you get
information about each individual
emitter but you can't draw a picture of
what's happening environmentally on the
ground and we worked with the University
of Massachusetts to divide the country
up into one by one squares and and look
at what the actual impact was and look
at prevailing winds and look at the
cumulative total of that and then mapped
it against proximity to schools because
is where young kids are for extended
periods of the day and it drew a very
different picture it took government
information on the one hand it was
publicly available but for all intents
and purposes is not actionable in any
way and transformed it into something
that provided a series of stories around
at it individual moment but actually
lives on today and as a continuing
resource for those communities to use
and is a way for them to hold individual
corporations accountable so I think it's
just one example of a different brand of
stories if you will that we can start
developing over time you know it
actually is actually two more very
quickly one is a lot of folk at what not
a lot but there's increasing focus on
hyper localism in terms of journalism
mention every block that you know
ostensibly came from public media and
then was went out in through the knight
Foundation and then went into the into
the private sector but there are other
examples of hyperlocal ism where they're
trying what in Philadelphia WHYY Christa
too low was ruining this project is one
of the premier civic engagement
journalists in the country ran the
editorial page at Enquirer and worked
with the city on helping them structure
the budget process with community
engagement and and he said trying to
apply those same lessons to working with
seven neighborhoods in Philadelphia
around how do you get the community to
work on both commercial and government
solutions to building that community to
be a better place and I think another
one I woulda site is lens on Atlanta
which is a project that's out of Atlanta
PDS it's focused on a public
broadcasting Elena I should say which is
focused on trying to give a platform to
citizens to talk about everything as
mundane as and like why is there this
huge pothole in my street to what's
happening in my community and why I
don't like it what is the great part
about that I think what's the sort of
the brilliant part is that Milton
clipper and the folks at pba are using
their journalistic you know cred to take
those stories and those conversations
and turn them into questions from a
journalistic point of view it's almost
in some ways crowdsourcing community
engagement into journalism versus the
other way around and asking so why is
there a pothole on this street or why
store are you doing these things so I
think those are examples where we're
getting a lot of experimentation what we
need to do now is invest in what works
and start to build build capacity
throughout the system so another
question over here right you wanted to
jump in so um go ahead this is the one
more question that I have one tweet
that's come in then a left that's why I
can't compete with me my name is
danielle martin i'm i'm here from MIT
from the urban studies and planning
department but i'm also from the
community media in the youth media world
and i know this come up a couple times
that there's a difference between a
mediated and an unmediated space but i
wonder if folks on the panel had some
opinions about is there a leadership
role that public media as its defined by
who's sitting at this panel here kid
play in you know getting people to use
more social media and community media
like public access stations and
collective enterprises that aren't quite
as mediated to have there be more public
interest and more legitimacy to those
endeavors I think that's a great
question i mean it caused a bit to
appraise the new Jeana used which is
this vision of a new public media
network which I think implies a more
expansive sense of who we are beyond
perhaps the entities constituted here
hopefully partnering with and actually
helping showcase and elevate some of the
groups that are doing amazing work in
other domains where some of the both the
audience reach the platform and
technology some of the journalistic
skills and training that can come with
it really could help I think raise up a
much broader segment than we've seen to
date let me throw to you guys talk about
where you see that as the opportunity I
mean what is the vision of the new
public media network all right you know
a lot of some of that is what we think
about when I was talking about world two
point oh and I really think about it as
partnerships with groups outside of our
who themselves are creating community to
really look at individual youth media of
Oakland comes to mind just me because
you talked about young people but he's
media use media who would partner with
us on this of guys at bay back or one
economy or their people we talked to who
whose work own work could be expanded
and exposed and could attract more
people because we're partnering in that
case there there the authorities not the
public broadcaster the public
broadcaster has the platform and the
opportunity to really bring people more
people to the question but I imagine I'm
imagining the kinds of things we could
get back are going to be pretty
tremendous even in our smaller efforts
at wgbh because the open lab open call
we did with a nova program attached to
an Adobe youth program to really come
back and talk about heat and climate
change and I always find that in those
sorts of partnerships the kind of
questions the approach the perspectives
the whole thing is much enriched and I
see us doing more of that and not less I
think we're moving in that direction so
as a segue for sooner maybe to jump in
that question the the tweet that came in
was asking you about how do you recruit
new producing talent yeah well over the
last two years we've had a twenty-two
percent increase in and growth in the
organization and over the last nine
months or so we've begun to actually
survey these people to say who are you
and why are you coming to us so and I'll
answer that question in a second but
just to give you some insight and maybe
to respond to that question a bit is
what we're seeing emerge is the
sixty-seven percent of the new members
coming are under the age of 34 55
percent are you know we're an
organization of independence in radio
fifty-five percent are primarily
oriented to broadcast radio but we're
seeing this growth in online orientation
thirty percent of the new members coming
in are oriented to on
and then there's subcategories of print
in other sort of forms of media so
another and twenty-five percent are
non-caucasian so we're seeing emerge I
think its kind in Turpan it is kind of
reflective of the larger world of people
who are again taking tools into their
own hands and and I I would say that
they lead us as Morita's suggesting they
sort of had the power to lead us to
these other places in these other
collaborations and partnerships and the
opportunity and exciting opportunity is
for again how we create the pathway for
this group into the legacy institutions
the tweet in terms of recruitment it's
sort of viral it's sort of I think it's
very much word of mouth with our
organization the MQ to project we it was
a competitive it was a competitive call
out to producers to get grant money so
we reached far and it always helps to
offer grant money routing technique
money money that's a good night room in
school so we're winding down and I
thought I would give a chance for the
panelists to offer some closing comments
one of the things that we didn't really
get to touch much on but has been
interesting is it bubbled up elsewhere
is that part of the landscape that's
really exploded over the last number of
years as we've been observing the media
transition are these other platforms
we're talking about building a public
media platform but here we are with
YouTube and with Facebook and the
Twitter clearly enabling a huge amount
of public participation of distribution
of a lot of things that you know when
public broadcasting was created for
years ago we felt was actually the thing
that was missing that we needed to
address those circumstances have changed
where do you see as you think through on
the positive side of Public Media's
leadership role in this where we need to
be creating that capacity and where
we're really hoping to leverage others
who are building those platforms so just
yeah just briefly I just say it you know
five years ago februari YouTube launched
and Huffington Post launched five years
ago not not this month but recently you
see the acceleration of those platforms
is a
credible I mean there ty have an
eight-year-old and so there are only
five years old can you imagine when they
get really dangerous i think that you
know i think that the challenges is for
public media to work outside of itself
and start to innovate with these
technology companies and young people
and collaborate and and it's a very
exciting time right now because public
media and large measure is exciting to
do that so this is going to be critical
a couple of years and in fact i have to
give some kudos to eugene and the rest
of folks at FCC are really very
thoughtfully trying to engage public
broadcasting in in this work so one of
one of the things that struck me coming
into public radio is the extraordinary
loyal to the audience and the level of
trust and extent to which people not
only have an affinity for what we do as
broadcasters and but potentially for
each other and and it is in a sense a
latent network if you will of people who
imagine that they have something in
common with others who listen and shared
experience most of which we've not yet
succeeded in bringing online the
opportunity and the platforms that you
mentioned is to do precisely that and to
recognize that our job is to make sure
that we're connecting people and that
we're getting information in front of
them wherever they're consuming
information we've seen a shift just in
the last year as the percentage of
referral traffic that's coming in from a
variety of different quarters search is
still the highest but RSS used to be
second and now it's social media that
has displaced RSS so you're moving from
sort of Morgan mechanical distribution
platform to one that's based more on
individuals and networks and I think
that's all I going to accelerate I see
these you know these are tools for us
that our our work is really of our work
which has to do with voice and
connection and education and dialogue
and these are tools and the more than
the better I mean it's really how do I
use YouTube and if it's Facebook how do
we use Facebook so we're content
creators
we're engaged now in serious
partnerships with people who are they
said very much outside public
broadcasting with our publix and that's
what the excitement is I think where we
can use whatever's out there how we
adapt and now we structure our content
to fit that particular framework that's
fine that's kind of why we're in the
business and I am I find the
partnerships to do that I've been very
you up I i work with everybody at this
table Corporation for Public
Broadcasting prx air NPR PBS I mean they
not that many of us out here so we're
running hard we're running hard and and
and I think are happy to feel that we're
now part of a much larger a community of
people who are also running hard so you
know bring on the youtubes bring it on
the youtubes okay well we'll close I
suppose with that thank you to our
panelists to think everybody here I
think